l'été c'est souvent la mère du sable
dans l'oeil aux interfaces y est et des
baignades récréative mes dents longues
et parfois un animal certes joli mais
qui a le fâcheux inconvénient de piquer
ou plutôt de brûler si on s'en approche
trop tout l'été des tc vous aide à aig
et les pièges et les dangers qui
menacent votre bien-être et votre santé
d'aider ses partenaires de votre été
vous avez forcément déjà entendu ce
qu'on conseille de faire en cas de
piqûre de méduse
il faut uriné sur la zone touchée mais
est ce que ça marche vraiment et surtout
est-ce que ce serait pas un peu de jus
[Musique]
vous quittez la medusa sur cette accule
des cellules urticantes à plénée matos
east qui se plante dans votre peau et
vous injecte du venin grâce à de
minuscules aiguilles
normalement ça leur sert à paralyser des
petites bestioles pour pouvoir les
manger sans qu'elle gigote mais sur les
grosses bestioles en vous bah ça pique
enfin ça brûle bon mais en cas de piqûre
de méduse que vous voulez savoir c est
ce que vous êtes vraiment obligés de
courir sur la plage en hurlant s'il vous
plaît à quelqu'un hurler mois dessus la
chaleur inactive le venant des méduses
c'est un fait et l'uriné
bah c'est chaud en plus contrairement à
ce qu'on pense ce n'est pas sale
puisqu'à la inverse du cac à luri est
garanti sans doute sans son micro à part
en cas d'infection urinaire le pipi
c'est stérile du coup c'est vrai que
c'est tentant
bah oui mais non non parce qu'en réalité
quand la piqûre de méduse vous gratte ou
vous qui a qu'une petite partie des
nemat aussi présente sur votre peau qui
ont déjà injecté leur revenant l'idée
c'est d'empêcher les autres de le faire
et lure income l'eau douce à risque de
les exciter et de déclencher l'injection
de leurs cochonneries
après si vous avez vraiment envie de
courir partout sur la plage en hurlant
uruguay dessus c'est vous qui voyez moi
juge pas le mieux à faire c'est d'abord
de sortir de l'eau pour pas se noyer en
cas de malaise
ensuite de ne pas gratter la zone de
retourner la rincer à l'eau de mer sans
frotter de revenir sur la plage et de
coller dessus une bonne dose de sable
chaud puis d'attendre un peu et de
retirer le sable et toutes ces saletés
de cellules en raclant avec un bout de
carton ou une carte de crédit
ensuite mettez l'antiseptique dessus et
allez voir votre formation qui vous
donnera ce qu'il faut en général ils
sont habitués en bord de mer pour calmer
la douleur vous pouvez aussi trempé
l'endroit où vous avez été piquées dans
l'eau chaude pendant une vingtaine de
minutes
si vous ressentez ce qu'on appelle des
signes généraux c'est à dire pas juste
localisées au niveau de la piqûre allez
voir votre médecin
surtout si vous avez déjà été piqué
plusieurs fois parce que dans ces cas là
ça peut être une réaction anaphylactique
c'est à dire votre corps qui met en
branle un système de défense puissants
pour combattre un venin qu'il connaît
déjà et ça peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques
dernière chose ne jouez pas avec les
méduses morte sur la plage parce que
leurs tentacules reste actif plusieurs
semaines même détachée du corps actif
well pas actives qu'on dit un tentacule
c'est masculin comme un testicule
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve dans 15 jours pour une
nouvelle vidéo spéciale était difficile
à muri n'est pas n'importe où sauf si on
me le demande gentiment et portez vous
[Musique]